well military option is definitely on
the table of uh president putin he's
considering it but we have all the
possibilities to deter him from
resorting to this option
and there is a big work underway right
as we speak between kiev washington
london brussels paris and berlin to set
up a comprehensive deterrence package
that will
make president putin think twice
before resorting to a military option
and what is your estimates of the size
of the russian forces that have been
masked on the board are we getting u.s
intelligence reports that talk about
something like 70 000 troops but more
potentially backing them up
well we can now speak of 115 000 troops
concentrated along our border but also
in the occupied territories of ukraine
in crimea and in donbas
the issue as you rightly mentioned is
that russia can bring more troops very
quickly
because the infrastructure for them was
rolled out rolled out in back in spring
during the first wave of escalation so
all they need to do now is just to move
soldiers into
there and give them orders well let's
talk about the issue of deterrence
and of course the two presidents spoke
very recently president putin and
president biden and president biden made
it very clear to the russians that there
would be huge consequences of such an
incursion occurred but it would not go
into military action it would involve
economic sanctions is that enough for
ukraine well ukraine has been fighting
this war for seven years at the same
time we achieved
big results in transforming the country
in attracting in developing trade
attracting investment this is not an
easiest thing when you have two pieces
of your territory occupied by four in
power
uh we understand that it will be us who
will be fighting for our country we are
capable of doing that and we are willing
to do that if we are attacked but
economic package is absolutely the the
package of economic sanctions is
absolutely essential if we want to deter
putin and that's what all of us want to
achieve to avoid the worst case scenario
just be very clear about that foreign
minister what you've just said there
about the price that putin and russian
forces would pay
if they fought
all the way in to ukraine
what the pushback would be and what what
the military action would involve from
your side
we together with partners we have to
make this price unbearable for putin
they can strike economically we will be
fighting on the ground
and i'm sorry to say that but there will
be
a lot of dead russian soldiers and
we hope that president putin does not
want that to happen right none of us
nobody of course wants to see that
happen so let's explore then further
about the potential sanctions we've got
the united states leading the allies
pushing back against putin saying we
will really tighten the screw
economically do you think that would be
enough though do you think that the
russians will back off
well if
russian leadership is rational
they do not want
to cause
a catastrophe for russia
by causing a catastrophe to ukraine in
europe by attacking us
this will not be a local conflict this
the entire europe will suffer from
consequences if president putin decides
to move forward
so if the west strikes back with this
most severe sanctions that have never
been put in place before
that will mean a catastrophe for russian
economy and russian people so it's a
lose-lose game for everyone and we want
to send the clear message to president
putin that ukraine and partners are
united
and we want a win-win solution we want
peace and justice for ukraine and for
europe there's one very specific piece
of economic action i know that ukraine
wants to see already and this involves
the supply of gas from russia to europe
through the north stream 2 pipeline it's
already completed it has not been
approved just as we speak today a new
german chancellor has been formally
installed in olaf schultz he has
inherited from his predecessor angela
merkel the the ambition to continue with
nordstrom 2. would you like to see that
ruled out all together now and the
russians told that we will not take your
gas
north stream 2 is a bad project for
ukraine for europe
and for transatlantic
unity
we're looking forward to discussing with
the new german government how they see
this project being kind of
developed further but for us it is
obvious that russia is already using it
as a weapon against ukraine as a way to
weaken
uh ukraine so um we will be very
appreciative and very consistent in
opposing north stream too because this
is not the luxury that russia should be
should be given what about uh military
aid from from the west from nato
countries in terms of not in terms of
personnel but in in terms of armaments
so we know that ukraine has acquired
drones from from turkey and that some
u.s military advisors are on the ground
in ukraine would you like to see further
support in that direction
um when russia
had launched it had started its
escalation ukraine came up with a very
simple idea comprehensive deterrence
package that consists of three layers
political messaging sanctions and
reinvigorated military and defense
cooperation with ukraine and we see
progress being made on all three tracks
there are no embargoes no restrictions
on trading weapons with ukraine all we
want is defensive weapons because strong
ukraine militarily strong ukraine is a
deterrence measure in itself how many
u.s military advisors are there in
ukraine at the moment and what role are
they playing
well three countries uh
uh rolled out uh their uh instructors
programs in 2014 the united states
canada and the united kingdom
uh this program has been very successful
we learned from your instructors but
also your instructors learned from the
ukrainian army that has been fighting a
real modern war with russia so it's
mutually beneficial for all but i insist
these are only instructors they're not
the combat force on the ground
and there are thousands of them on the
ground they're training our soldiers but
they're not taking part in any military
activities but if it did come to combat
as you mentioned there um that many
russians would die in this combat would
as would many ukrainians we imagine as
well would you want to see ultimately
support in terms of personnel from nato
members
well the arrival of nato troops into a
conflict zone will mean a direct
conflict between
russia and nato
i think this is the scenario that all
sides want to avoid i want to make it
clear ukraine is a strong country we did
not fall
under the enormous pressure on russia in
2014 when our army was extremely weak we
have a completely different army now we
have a resilient society we know how to
fight we do not ask anyone to fight for
us what we are asking is to help us to
avoid the war or if we are left with no
alternative because of russia's
willingness to launch a war then help us
uh to strengthen our army and to make it
more efficient but it is this role of
nato which is perhaps at the heart of
the matter certainly in terms of
russia's ambitions they made it very
clear they do not want nato expanding
ever closer to its borders it is
ukraine's ambition is it not to have a
closer relationship with nato and
ultimately join it
well this is a completely
uh trumped-up argument of russia because
they know perfectly that ukraine's
membership in nato is not on the agenda
today and it will not be decided
tomorrow it's a strategic goal
and there is no direct threat to
russia it's actually russia that poses a
threat to nato not the other way around
but they're coming up with this argument
looking for an excuse for aggressive
action and we shouldn't shouldn't be
buying it under no circumstances but you
understand their sensitivity about nato
old foes of course cold war foes and
dimitri pescov president putin's
spokesman has said you've got to
understand we have red lines too
the red line of russia is the border of
russia this is the line that no one has
the right to cross and we fully agree
with it so far it's only russia who
crossed the border with georgia in 2008
and with ukraine in 2014
so we should not allow russian officials
to put the whole discussion upside down
and to make everyone think about their
red lines instead of making russia
respect our red lines it's what's
happening on the ukrainian border part
of the the same process that's taking
place
between the borders of belarus and and
poland and some of the baltic countries
sanctioned obviously by allowed
obviously by president putin with that
migrant crisis that's going on there
this is this is president putin
pushing at in particular the european
union's borders absolutely russia is
interested in weak ukraine and weak
europe
and this is why what is happening along
the border with ukraine is a part of a
broader picture
the tensions the raising tensions in
bosnia and herzegovina
migrants trying to cross into the
european union
from belarus north stream to
disinformation campaigns cyber attacks
these are all efforts are taken by
russia to shatter europe to make it
weaker and basically the logic is simple
russia creates a problem and then
invites others to a discussion and ask
them to make concessions in order to
resolve problems this is the tactics
employed
used by by russia so what do you think
the response it's interesting what you
say though what do you think the
response should be to that because i've
read the analysts as well saying that
that well you know if russia really was
going to invade why would it be so
explicit about its buildup of forces
they know about american satellites
they're going to see the troops and the
tanks building up there they're sending
a message they're not intending to
invade and they know as you've described
to us foreign minister there what a
heavy price they would pay if they were
fighting ukrainians on ukrainian soil it
was very different when they when they
annexed crimea a
lot of support there from the
russian-speaking people there this would
be very different to try to hold that
territory as you say they would pay a
very heavy price so this is just about
negotiations so should if anything be
given to president putin to deter it
well first
the takeover of crimea was done at the
boreal of russian gun not because there
was someone supporting
russia's arrival
on the peninsula this is important
second
back in 2014 russia was convincing
everyone that's not us we are not doing
it we are not intervening these are
unidentified green men who are doing it
so but they still did it we all faced it
and what russia wants to achieve now is
to
again test
two things the strength and the unity of
the collective west this is not only
about ukraine this is about far much
much broader broader discussion and if
someone is asking a question
let's give putin something in order to
uh
deter him
uh the question is how far do we have to
go in giving putin something we have
this experience in in europe
the pre-second world war politicians
followed the same logic let's give
something let's let's stop him let's
make him uh satisfied but it didn't stop
him we shouldn't fall into that logic
again we should clearly demonstrate that
the collective west is strong and united
and is capable to deter russia without
compromising its principles okay so no
concessions to russian demands uh you're
meeting the foreign secretary in london
today what are you going to ask
specifically the uk to do right now in
terms of that deterrence well if i may i
will correct you we are constructive and
we are ready to make concessions if this
is reciprocated by russia
but
we will not be making concessions of
issues which are fundamental importance
for the development of ukrainian state
such as our european and euro-atlantic
integration
demands should be reasonable this and
legitimate the demand of russia for
ukraine to abandon its foreign policy is
illegitimate the demand of russia to
demand from ukraine to coordinate with
russia our integration to nato or
abandon it is illegitimate it will only
be the people of ukraine who will be
making their choice
uh when i see the secretary uh
the foreign secretary um in london we
will discuss uh two things security and
trade we have a
very advanced partnership uh and
security in in the field of security
with the united kingdom and it's much
appreciated
but
we have the same level of potential in
boosting trade and investment and will
be a big big issue for all of us because
again the stronger ukraine becomes
militarily and economically the less
will be the temptation for president
putin to attack us but it is that's you
know the trade the security always
looking west the in ukraine and this is
the problem for the russians as you say
they've they've made it very clear it
doesn't look like we're going to get a
solution anytime soon ukraine made its
choice in 2014
to
move irreversible
irreversibly towards the west to come
back where it belongs we are not
newcomers
the largest part of our history was
a part of the european history it's only
the last 300 years that we had been part
of russia
so our
king's princess and nobility felt like
at home in germany and france in london
300 years ago we are coming where we
belong and it will be only us who will
decide the future of this country
dimitro caleb thank you very much indeed
for joining us on sky news thank you